[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
movement watches and that is spelled MV
MT movement watches I first became aware
of this company back in 2014 when their
a brand brand new baby company because
they won first place in Shopify's built
a business competition the founders are
two college dropouts who wanted to wear
fancy watches but had one wee little
problem they couldn't afford fancy
watches so they decided to scratch their
own itch since then their high quality
affordable watches have gone from
startup to more than 1 million watches
sold across 160 countries it's an
awesome success story and when you check
out the product you'll know why they
offer classic design quality
construction and many different modern
styles so you can really pick one that
suits you you might want to start one I
would suggest probably appeal to a lot
of folks out there's the classic black
silver so search classic black silver
the guys at movement have a great offer
for listeners of this podcast they're
offering 15% off your entire purchase
with free shipping and free returns if
you're dissatisfied for any reason and
they are very very famous for their
customer support
just visit movement watches dot-com or /
Tim that's MV MT watches comm forward
slash Tim
this podcast is brought to you by mizzen
and Maine many of you longtime listeners
know how I feel about visit in Maine
they make the most comfortable dress
shirts in the world
quite possibly they use advanced
performance fabrics which provides
stretch and comfort but that's not the
real selling point to me that's all
great it's all really good but they are
the only dress shirts so to speak that I
travel with because you don't have to
iron them no more steaming no more
headache I can just bunch them up and
throw them in a bag pull them out and no
one will be the wiser they're fancy
enough for important dinners but made
from athletic sweat wicking material so
they're all-purpose and hundreds of pro
athletes love these shirts including NFL
all-pro JJ Watt and last time these guys
were on the show they sold out of every
item they featured every single SKU so
if you're interested in getting a shirt
you might want to check them out on the
faster side just go to Tim dot blog
forward slash shirts and you can receive
$50 off when you purchase three or more
shirts so check it out Tim dot blog
forward slash shirts
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types whether they come
from the worlds of business chess
military sports you name it in this case
poker this episode of the podcast
features Phil Hellmuth at Phil
underscore Hellmuth h-e-l-l-o mute eh
who has one more word who is way more
okay we have polka World Series of Poker
bracelets than any other person in
history I'm not drunk I'm high on life
this interview comes from my television
show fearless fear and in parentheses
less because the objective is to learn
to fear less not be fearless in which I
interview world-class performers on
stage about how they've overcome doubt
conquered fear and made their toughest
decisions you can watch the entire first
episode with illusionist David Blaine
for free at att.net forward slash
fearless so you can check that out and
to watch all episodes just visit direct
tv.com or check out your account on
DirecTV so DirecTV com that is with one
t di r ec t v-- comm we recorded about
three hours of material when Phil and I
sat down and only one hour was used for
the TV show that means this podcast is
almost entirely new content that did not
appear in the television episode in this
conversation we explore many things
including Phil's morning routine the
importance of goals and blessings how he
became the youngest person to win the
World Series of Poker his prep for the
high stakes games in which he plays what
it takes to compete at the highest level
and much much more also since we
recorded the show Phil published his
autobiography poker brat
well titled you can check that out so
with all of that said please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Phil
Hellmuth and let's get started right
meow enjoy
welcome to fearless I'm your host Tim
Ferriss and on this stage will be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all types to uncover and distill the
specific tactics they've used to
overcome doubt tackle their hardest
decisions and ultimately succeed on
their own terms so let's do show of
hands how many people here think they
can tell when someone is lying I'm 50%
now how many of you think you can lie
and not get caught 30 how many of you
who raised your hands would be willing
to bet your entire life savings on being
able to do that all right
6 or 7 well for the last 30 years my
guest tonight has made his living
reading behavior analyzing the odds and
gambling for his future in 1989 he
became the youngest main event champion
at the World Series of Poker and he
holds the world record for most event
wins at 14 and he's still going please
welcome author entrepreneur and
professional poker player Phil Hellmuth
I can always tell if I have a lot of
friends watch poker and I'm an avid fan
but not a competent player so we're not
gonna be at the same table any time and
listen to spectator but I can always
tell when you're on because of the
beeping the good news is this isn't
really family programming so no bleeps
in this conversation if it all comes out
I want to talk a little bit about the
scrout you trying to encourage me to
swear you know this is my I'm from Long
Island it might come out on my part I do
drop f-bombs if I get wound up so ah
yeah I guess that's light nudge but
swearing swearing is part of the lexicon
now and things have changed so much you
know you know and so I do probably swear
more that I should even when I'm on the
microphone doing events you know and
someone will be like there's always one
or two people of the couple hundred at
the event they're offended they usually
don't say anything that's pretty good I
mean that's pretty pretty good
percentage I mean that's that's a good
win
like I have a goal sheet on my mirror
and I have a blessing sheet on my mirror
so at the morning when I'm brushing my
teeth and not paying attention I see
what my lifetime goals are or my goals
for that year and then I also see my
blessings
so I leave hopefully happy because I've
see the blessings and focused because I
know what my goals are so for me that's
you know some of the some of these so
let me just wrap this up this is kind of
fun so the other day I was at Starbucks
three or four months ago and someone
came up to me and I was really tired it
was a Sunday morning and I had slept
well and someone came up to me that
doesn't know me that well or whatever
but I'm polite and I smiled and I shook
his hand or whatever and just wanted to
get my coffee and get out of there and
then his wife pops up and she's just
glowing
she's like Phil I got to tell you I was
at your speech I put my goals up on my
mirror and I accomplished him with
within two months and she was glowing
and I thought wow I had a profound
influence on her life and it just made
me feel like I mean I know as a
professional poker player at the top of
the game I do things no one else does in
the game and I know that I'm motivated
I've known I've known this since maybe
2002 where where someone came up to me
and they said Phil I was in a coma and I
went and I woke up because I imagine
playing you heads-up at poker and this
guy sat down in the audience when I was
playing heads up for a World
Championship and my wife said he sat
down and you won 11 hands in a row and
she said there's something weird here
and so from that moment on way back in
2002 I realized that I'm motivating you
know that I'm inspirational to people
not the stuff the you see on television
although that's kind of fun to watch me
beeping and whatever but me performing
at the top of what I do you know I mean
you watch some great athletes
do things no other great athletes can do
I like watching Tiger Woods at his prime
I like watching Michael Jordan now I'm
not as big as those guys but in my
industry I it's kind of fun to see wow
how did Phil know that to fold this or
move in with this and so yeah I think I
think when you're H what I'm a cheating
the most I can achieve and I'm playing
poker like no one else has ever seen I
think that that can be inspirational for
you know millions of people that watch
it so we in that period when you're
struggling do you have any particular
coping mechanisms or strategies that you
use things to occupy your time that
helped you get through that absolutely
big coping mechanism for me and this
applied itself in poker too because when
you're young in poker
you're usually reckless so I told you I
won the main event seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for first right
this is 1989 men so you know and I'd
been taking way too many chances and and
so at that point from there yes I was
smart I bought a penthouse condominium
you know and paid cash for it
yes I put aside money for taxes but the
other three hundred thousand dollars I
lost so yeah I ended up with and I mean
may have bought a couple cars so
beautiful cars had house condominium but
I'm struggling to pay $800 a month condo
fees it's like a year later and so the
coping mechanism there is rather than
it's not that I'm avoiding the present
it's that you're like this is a moment
where there's a lot of rain so number
one I'm going to develop strategies for
the next time I have money my money
management system has to be really solid
and I have to actually apply it and use
it that's number one number two I would
I would look forward and I'd say all
right what does it look like in two
years
it looks amazing in two years and so in
the depths of dealing with some of the
worst times
I would take advantage of that down
period of that being trodden down to be
more focused alright how did this happen
how can I play poker better how can I
mount money man but money management's
more important than playing poker or
poker players oh yeah
McCann ask me about that later but
that's a very interesting topic yeah
what to go with it you know
so that was those those are the kind of
things I would use Vince Vaughn was
talking about this last night here you
know he he told me he taught me
something that I hadn't thought about
much when someone's looking at a flop
they usually haven't hit it they're
trying to figure out do I have anything
go flop meaning when the dealer when the
first three cards come out yes but you
have to pay attention to all that tells
a story yeah look at it
for a long time they're trying to figure
out what to make of their hand whereas
they look at it quickly then either have
nothing or we were talking about
potentially strong position that was a
great observation his part it made me
realize how smart he is increased my
respect factor for him because he
because he got it and pointed out
something that I hadn't been paying
attention to recently but everything
adds up it's a picture you know and and
how much are they betting and and when
the next card comes off now there's four
in the middle how much are they betting
and when the fifth card comes up how
much are they betting are they
hesitating because they think I have to
bluff all in here and I have to man up
to do it and then when they Bluff that
they put it in right away or do they
wait mm-hmm
you know and then people try to use
things to throw you off sure so you have
to decipher the whole picture so I trust
my instincts
and when I'm on I look I look great yeah
but I'm just not on every day so you
know we film so much poker yeah there's
days where I'm off and then a million of
the kids watch it and they say Phil
sucks at poker Phil sucks at poker Phil
sucks at poker
I hear that I've heard that's so often
in my life that I'm not good at poker
it's crazy to me
it's because they watch my worst moments
and I think I wonder if I watched this
guy who's criticizing that for watched
all of his worst moments yeah you know
the blooper trail for somebody else
probably so you're talking about you
know when you're at your best and by the
way yeah that can get to me people you
know I mean people were telling me I
wasn't good at poker coming into the
game and passed me by coming into 2010 I
sucked at poker you know you know
because I hadn't done anything in a
couple of years and I mean it would
internet forums filled with how bad I
was at poker because I'm a big target
yeah and because I hadn't done anything
lately and that's fair criticism yeah
and then all of a sudden 2011 came and I
had you know three second-place finishes
and everybody's like wow and in 2012
came and I won two bracelets and
everybody's like oh my god but I swear
I'll never forget this 2011 they were
talking about how how I was like I had
fallen out of the top 500 and poker how
I sucked at the game exactly three weeks
later I had two second-place finishes
and they were talking about how was the
greatest I was just like all right what
changed I was giving some advice early
on when I was when I was writing I was
getting really thrown for a loop with
some criticisms I remember the first
time I got a negative Amazon review the
very first time you out and I wrote this
really logic logical compassionate
replied this like long I spent hours on
this thing and the guy was like go [ __ ]
yourself I was like oh the humanity why
won't you listen Internet and somebody
said to me you never as bad as they say
you are and they're you're never as good
as they say you are either and I was
like did you then stop reading reviews I
stopped reading most of them on Amazon
and YouTube in a few places where it's
like always devolves to like Hitler
after like two pages like haven't get to
Hitler like it's a kitten video but the
what I wanted to ask you before I get
too far right so you just kind of gave
like I stopped looking at poker forms
5,000 won yeah I just stopped looking
yeah well I think it's like you don't
you it's there's there's how to deal
with something and then there's choosing
not to like strategically choosing not
to deal with it
so sometimes it's easier to not go where
it's slippery if you don't a slip right
so it's just like with temptation with
the quality problem but like beautiful
smart women kind of swarming around when
you're in Vegas or something like that
similarly it's like well I don't want to
have to waste the energy to manage my
response to something that isn't going
to be productive anyway because the good
stuff is just gonna make my head inflate
and the bad stuff isn't going to be
probably even accurate or it's gonna
make me feel terrible so what's the
outcome that I'm looking for but what I
want to ask you because you know my
whole life to stay with that a second my
whole life has been you know I would get
too inflated by the good stuff my ego
gets all pumped up yeah
now you get to devastated by the bad
stuff you know what I mean and and I
look back and I was very defensive in a
lot of the videos that you may or may
not show but a lot of these videos super
defensive until 2011 2012 but I'm like
wait a minute I'm the all-time champion
I have all the records why am i so
defensive yeah and I think that's part
of that defensiveness that that's part
of maybe ties in I want to be I want to
be great yeah and I want everybody to
think I'm great yeah at games
specifically poker and and I think that
might may drive me yeah I'm trying to
get away from being defensive yes it's
tough I'm pretty defensive too I mean I
remember I tweet today and I was like
what yeah twitter twitter I'm her
Stephen Fry opted out well-known
comedian actor of being on Twitter and
it's like too many people have peed in
the pool he's like I'm out air they're
gonna break from pit from Twitter yeah
Chris but useful metaphor anyway I want
to talk about one of the times maybe you
weren't at your best you've lost all
this money just to go back to where we
were in your timeline and I'd read about
you setting a number of goals maybe in a
taxicab am i making this up there were a
few goals one was World Series of Poker
believe if this is fiction let me know
ii was no no optic I've got it I've got
it from here yeah so so I mean this this
was probably I was 21 I guess maybe 20
to something like that and and I had
this kind of like one of these weird
touch points or something amazing
happens to me weird right so I'm playing
poker in Madison Wisconsin I wake up and
it's foggy and it's you know and there's
snow on the ground and I'm like you know
and I'm looking at a two and four dollar
limit game but I have twenty thousand
dollars you go to that game you might
make two hundred bucks right so but why
do I what's what am i doing you know and
so I go over there and I'm bored and I
don't wanna and there's no golf courses
open and I can't find anything kind of
fun to do and so two of the guys from
the game I say hey let's go have a drink
so I've never been a big drug guy but I
smoke pot and then we go to the bar and
I'm having a drink and they're playing
pool for ten or twenty dollars a game
and it's like 1:00 in the afternoon yeah
yeah and I and I'm having a drink and
I've smoked pot and I'm suddenly like in
there arguing about twenty dollars at
the pool table and I'm like what the
[ __ ] am I doing with my life you know
and I'm like I gotta get out of here
yeah so I go and I and I'll never forget
I open this door right and boom like the
Sun is out now and it's bouncing off the
snow and it's just like it's like a
metaphor for what happened at that
moment was a reality of what happened at
that moment I opened the door and I saw
all the light right just and it's coming
at me and it's bouncing off everything
and I've been in some dingy bar and I'm
just like wow what is this and I call
for a taxi I would never drive when I'm
doing something silly like that yeah I
get back to my apartment and I'm like
what are you doing with your life and
the first thing I do I have all this
positive momentum and all this energy
and I'm like this is my lifetime goals
I'm going to win the main event the
World Series of Poker if under a poker
player I'm gonna be the best in the
world I'm gonna meet and marry an
amazing woman I'm gonna buy a beautiful
house I'm gonna buy a beautiful car and
that may be one or two outs I'm gonna
write a New York Times best-selling book
right so I said these are my lifetime
goals like six of them and then at all
this positive momentum and all this
energy and I'm like wow I in order to
get there how am I gonna do it well I
think of it as a pyramid first I have to
be able to not smoke pot not become an
alcoholic manage my money all these
little things on the bottom row of the
pyramid and then there's the next row of
the pyramid exercise eating healthy all
this stuff and the next year I'll make
sure that you're studying the game all
the way to the top so I designed a
pyramid in that moment just as creative
breakthrough them having right and and
then I'm like well actually I love the
concept of a pyramid and in poker the
money flows up so I designed that
pyramid in that moment I'm just writing
for hours like a madman and at the
bottom of the pyramid is like all the
small stakes games that might happen at
a bar and then all the home games and
then some of the games in Vegas and some
of the big games in LA all the money
flows up all the people that have
success here come to this level they
dump off the money or they go up most
dump off the money so the money flows
all the way up so if I want to be if I
want to win millions or deca millions
playing poker I have to be up here at
the top as a player and I have to use
this pyramid and make sure that I check
all the boxes on all these blocks to get
there right and I came up with the
concept
I'm overwhelming people know I have two
pyramids and a lifetime goal list and
then I decided it's important to have
something on my bathroom mirror which we
talked about a little bit already oh
yeah and so that concept came that day
so all this amazing positive momentum
but to me that was one of the most I'm
calling that in my autobiography poker
Brad I'm saying that chapters called I
can see the light
I just talked about that and then I'm
devising all these money management
strategies so what were some of your
that was a profound moment for me in my
life what were some of your because this
is this is I think a really critical
component as you alluded to earlier what
were some of those money management
strategies oh before before we Wellcome
to that but before I say the amazing
thing was with all those Bulls I looked
like a year later yeah my wife found the
list it may be two years later and I had
knocked off five of those lifetime goals
already I'd won the main event yeah
I'd met Cathy yeah you know I bought
this beautiful condominium I you know I
bought some beautiful cars and so just
it was amazing how many boxes I checked
now the best-selling book I didn't know
this in oh four when I put out play
poker like the pros I didn't know that
this would be the one I just saw the
poker wave coming and I put a how-to
book out there wrote it myself we talked
about this last night it took two months
1,500 words a day put it out there some
guy holds it up on ESPN he'd played a
seven card low tournament seven card Lok
what he never played before what does
that mean what's a seven card later so I
mean basically the World Series of Poker
as a seven-card stud tournament two
Hold'em tournament Omaha all these
different variations of Poker he's
playing in a seven card low he said I
read Phil Hellmuth book and he holds it
up holds it up on ESPN I read this book
and I catch for $17,000 not a million
yeah not two million $17,000 boom my
book gets the bestseller list yeah
so yeah that's a lifetime duel so I
remember HarperCollins calls me they
somehow I guess we had cellphones by
then so yeah so they they called me and
they said yeah where are you staying and
I'm like I'm at the I'm at the Loews
Hotel and they said okay your book just
hit the New York Times bestseller list
we just sent a bottle of Dom to your
room and I'm like and it was a how-to
list so I just walked around high for
weeks cuz that was one of the last bowls
that I had accomplished yeah yeah and
there's so many directions if he could
go but I'm gonna go back to the well
money management yes sir so at that time
because this is this is a a critical
survival skill it seems like I mean
foundational for I'm buddy came back
this because I think the people out
there should know this yeah
what's more important great poker skills
or great money management money
management I'll tell you why if you have
a guy that has poker skills let's do a
diagram here poker skills of sick of 80
let's say poker skills of 90 okay and
you have a guy poker skills of 80 but
the guy with 80 manages money better
he's gonna have a much more comfortable
life he's gonna win his money he's gonna
sit down in the smart games at the right
time with the right amount of money and
he's just gonna flow along he's gonna
pay all of his bills it's gonna look
boring some of the outsiders gonna say
oh you're too conservative but meanwhile
look at the guy who is 90 alright but no
money management skills loses all his
money in one night yeah now he has to
borrow money from his friends loses that
too then he gets staked right that means
someone who's bankrolling someone banks
rolls him but he has so much skill that
he hits for 500,000 in a tournament okay
but his backer gets 250,000 but still
now he has 250,000 now he's back in
action you know and he has a couple of
successful month's runs is up to 400,000
but then over a series of two weeks
loses the whole 400,000 borrows from all
of his friends again because he paid him
back last time this time he borrows more
staked again that okay can't pay his
bill that's a miserable it's a tough
existence and so that's why money
management is more important than poker
skills now how specifically by running I
remember I remember story where my wife
thought I was a madman it was 1997 she
thought I was a man but I'm wondering
how many stories you have like that but
let's let's Lester this one so I
remember saying as soon as I'm worth a
million dollars I'm gonna get staked
that meant based on what my house was
worth on stocks all the stuff that I had
in my life and so I determined I hit the
million dollar mark this is in assets
yeah and assets call it 1997 and I was
on the way down and I was like all right
I'm getting staked I'm gonna have Ted
force take me you know cuz people were
lining up to stake me I had pretty good
results and so I'm gonna have Ted force
take me and I was celebrating honey I'm
getting staked
but I wasn't celebrating the fact that I
was getting staked I was celebrating the
fact that I could hit a million dollars
in net worth and gets staked no one in
history had done that to that point that
I have ever heard of everybody else
would go hey let's get two hundred
thousand dollars from the house let's
sell a car let's sell some stocks not me
so I was celebrating and my wife I just
remember in a hotel in San Francisco I
was all like yes you know and my wife
just was staring at me like with daggers
like what's wrong with you you're
getting steak then you're celebrating
but that wasn't it the point was I was
gonna draw this line in the sand and I
did it and I got staked for the next
three or four or five years until 2001
and and Ted and Ted Forrest was great
like like he like if I had money do if I
my bills were a lot less than if I had
five thousand a month and bills or seven
thousand or whatever it was he would
just like press a button and send me the
money and I was getting staked and I had
no worries I played less I spent more
time with my family at that point and
then all of a sudden 2001 I won five
hundred thousand tournaments quickly
and Ted was entitled to like 400 of it
maybe I want yeah 400 of it or whatever
and I was more than happy you know he
had faith in me and he made a bunch of
money because of me and that was great
but that's what discipline it takes to
have great money management and now
today I have a system where I'll only
risk ten thousand dollars a day what I'm
playing kids only risk ten thousand
dollars they know discussing the
percentage I'm proud of that because
actually if I could translate to people
at home I don't know what that would be
for someone at home take a guess
I mean I've done I've to guess your net
worth I don't know I forget nowhere or a
liquid assets yeah I would say it it's
something that you can comfortably lose
and not have it materially affect you
correct you're correct correct
and and I just figured and so for me
that was a big stuff I implemented this
five years ago
and and it's been super successful for
me because 10,000 doesn't last too long
in the games I play in yeah right but I
can't always tell when I've lost ten
whether I'm the reason I implemented it
I can't always tell if I'm playing
poorly or if I'm just getting unlucky
there's always there's always mystery
there mystery surrounding how good
you're playing and so I just decided
like for me it's been a great system if
I lose it I'm like all right I can't do
anything I can't play for 24 hours or
whatever till I wake up all right well I
might as well go to the movie I might
sleep a couple of times couple shifts
watch some movies in the room chill and
show up fresh the next day and there's I
don't want to lose ten today I just did
it yesterday so you come up like ready
to play you've thought about did I do
everything right so I mean that's that's
been a good system for me for the last
five or six years
how would you have reacted had you not
one I think it would have been
devastating but I would have still had
350 400,000 you have to understand at
that point I was already there were four
majors per year and then there were like
nine world series so that year they were
say 11 World Series of Poker
Championships and then there were like
three other ones who really wanted to
win which I considered majors and one of
them was the Bicycle Club main event and
I won that one in 1988 in August so I'd
already won one of the majors and was
all over the poker press and so to win
that was just kind of like you know that
that was the greatest moment maybe the
greatest moment in my poker career just
to win that it's nice to back it up
thirteen more time this is speaking of
backing it up at what point before 1989
so I know we're doing a little memento
style like chronologically fragmented
approach here but bear with me the I
don't know why I keep looking at you you
look like look like very pensive the the
question was which I appreciate it's
like thinking hard odd the the question
is when did Johnny show you his hand
this is what I've read maybe this is
also just myth and you saw something or
at least you told him uses well as
answering hand the answering thing about
this this is more for poker people I'll
try to I'll try to make it so everybody
can understand so the blinds were 5 and
10 thousand when we were heads up and
first thing I had whispered to Johnny
Chan we played 32 minutes I'd whispered
at the beginning you're gonna have to
play perfect and get lucky to beat me
now if the cameras had been working in
those days that that's one that would
have been played a lot and people would
have said boy that kids cocky but I wish
for it just searched and could hear and
exactly four hands before I had had the
a summit of diamonds I still remember
and I opened for thirty five thousand so
you have to think in terms of how much
money you're raising okay so that's
three and a half times the big blind
that's how they look at it these days at
3.5 pretty big but then sham called the
35 and raised a hundred and thirty
thousand more almost twice the size of
the pot these are unheard of big numbers
and a mental note went off I said I'm
not gonna play with him this hand but
he's stepping on the aggression now I
can see he's putting a lot of money he's
become very aggressive I'm gonna fold
this
I don't like folding it because
everybody else in the world back then
would put a lot of money in within any
ace especially a seven suited said I'm
gonna fold this but I noticed he's
changed his style and my mind was just
completely encompassed and how am I
gonna win this exactly four hands later
I looked at two black nines and it was
like the script was already written I'm
an open for thirty five thousand he's
gonna raise a hundred and thirty
thousand and I'm gonna just pile in
seven hundred thousand just boom that
quick and so it was like sometimes
scripts are written from hands and so I
did that he did it I waited I didn't
want to give anything away I didn't want
to show any excitement didn't want to do
anything that would change him from
doing what he was gonna do he re-raises
130-thousand the minute those chips hit
the pot I said I'm all-in
that's like he he started the hand with
six hundred thousand boom I'm raising
all your chips right back on you and and
it was two black nines a pretty strong
hand and now he started studying and
thinking and I thought to myself if he
had a sking or ace queen or ace jack or
a Stein he would have put the money in
already and those hands are very close
like maybe I'm a 12 to 10 13 to 10
favorite I don't want to play a pot
where I'm only 12 to 10 or 13 to 2 I
don't want to leave it to chance I also
thought that he would call with any pair
above tens instantly so at that point
I'm thinking wow what does he have do I
want him to call or not and I'd been
around poker long enough where I didn't
want to influence the action by saying
by acting strong or acting weak I said
just let things play out and see where
it lands but if he had King Queen I
didn't want him to call him only a small
favorite when he had the a seven of
spades I was kind of surprised also he
would have called right away with eights
or seventh which is a
great position for me when he had a
seven of spades I was kind of surprised
it was a little weaker and I think he
decided this kid is tough he and I had
faced off in the 1988 World Series he'd
seen me we'd faced off in August at the
tournament I won when I won the major at
the bicycle club that I just mentioned
and so he knew that I was there he'd
even come out in Esquire magazine in
January and said this kid is gonna win
the main event as soon as he learns to
tuck it in a little bit there was more
fuel for my fire reading myself a nice
square magazine that was a big thing man
back then you know nobody talked about
poker and so I just I and so when he
called with a seven of spades I was kind
of surprised but again I thought
already's gonna find a way to outdraw me
I mean it's just like it's not that I
felt the negativity it's more like you
have to be prepared for him to hit it
he's been lucky you've watched him get
lucky and so I mean when that six of
Spades hit I was you know Louis I was
near heaven I was going to tell you
about the question that Antonio asked me
that I told you about last night
let's let's jump into it okay another
subject switch for Phil yeah get used to
it
Antonio is a mutual friend very very
savvy investor in entrepreneurism we can
say his last name right sure Antonio
gracias
Antonio gracias amazing guys on the
board of Tesla SpaceX really great
friends with Elon Musk that's that we
meant originally yeah we met it an Elan
must party how lucky were we to be the
us it was like lose bracelets and we
ended up with like well especially me
this guy haven't come on 14 bridge suck
if I know I mean pretty amazing to be
there but anyway so you know Antonio
gracias last year my ego was flying out
of control I want a bracelet and then
for three months straight I was losing
maybe ten sessions I've never lost more
than three sessions that I can remember
for years lost 10 sessions in a row my
egos flying out of control right more
tempted than ever by these beautiful
smart women
you know and so I'm treading on this
Eagle path and I'm having fun every day
just popping from him doing events New
York Chicago appearances just like I
just feel like I just feel like I felt
like I was attracting everybody mm-hmm
and I'm just having a blast with it you
know and I'm in the Hamptons you know
and just all this fun stuff is happening
and so it's leading to a little bit of a
car wreck for me and then Antonio
gracias asked me he said Phil how many
bracelets would you have without your
wife and I wanted to answer selfishly
well I might have more cuz I'd play more
tournaments but I knew that wasn't true
yeah and I was like 9 he said you have
14 9 you really think you'd have that
money without her and I thought wow
maybe 7 and the minute that that
connected with me this egotistical guy
walking around not mistreating anybody
nice to everybody I've learned that you
know respect everybody I've learned that
but still flying high in his own like
jet stream you know just kind of like
boom and a week later my iPhone picture
was I had two iPhone pictures one on the
outside which was a Clinton eye and then
the other one on the inside George Bush
and I right so don't come at me I said
Democrats and Republicans but I erased
one and put my wife up and I erase the
other and I put my wife and sons up over
the next two weeks and as I did it I
thought wow this is the Antonio effect
right
you know he's I think I think if Ilan's
ever struggled which of course he never
has I think Antonio's helped him out
he's just been amazing and so just that
one question just kind of I felt like it
rerouted my life a little bit and then
in four sessions in my home game I won
so much money I won like 4x what I'd
lost over the last three months and I
just became more solidly entrenched in
the process like that was the key family
first
mm-hmm then you have your fun movie star
life where all these great things
happened but family first and so that
was significant for me just that
question yeah so on a related note this
is a question from Facebook Melanie
Nelson what's the secret to his long
lasting marriage so I just love to know
I mean I'm gonna tweak it a little bit
but what other things have you done
right I mean it's what other things have
you worked on how have you worked on
making it this long I mean it's a rarity
in this world at least in the u.s. it's
rare you know and it hasn't it's not
always easy
um and I think one thing is that you
know I still great desire for my wife I
still lost after honey I love you and
that's important to keep that it's
important to keep that I think for me
you know I think my wife was probably
ready to leave me in 99 like who the
hell is this guy I married
a diamond in the rough he's still in the
rough yeah you're still you're still a
piece of hole what did what did I mean
what you were supposed to change and
grow up you're a smart guy her
threatening to leave me devastated me
and but my wife's smart so she didn't do
anything drastic we went into therapy
together and I worked really hard at all
my faults too much ego too self-centered
too narcissistic blah blah blah right a
lot a lot of stuff it was really
important to work on and I saw the truth
in all of that and I was thinking about
it every week we'd spent an hour and a
half two hours three hours a week and
you know figuring out how things I might
have done wrong to her mostly
unintentionally sometimes I'd be trying
to do her a favor but of course
sometimes women think differently than
men men are from Mars owner
Venis right so I learned a lot about
that stuff and it changed my primary
relationship so I grew for a year and a
half massive growth and what I found is
all the other relationships changed one
of my friends JonBenet II was crying in
the car Phil it's the first time you've
listened to me in ten years crying Wow
and I was like that's okay that's my
wife's effect yeah you know so in
changing the primary relationship and
focusing and becoming better it made me
smarter and wiser and all my other
relationships and it helped my poker -
because poker is a people game yeah and
so so I think so I at the end of it I
was like well she made me into a better
man and we ended up coming out like this
and so I remember six months later I'm
like man I miss this growth I want to go
back into therapy just so I can get
better and grow more and so I mean
that's one thing that's that's been
really smart for us and then you know I
mean and then you know in the 30s we all
know that a lot of women are leaving men
and in the 40s a lot of men are leaving
women the the math and the science are
undisputed and so when I struggled a
little bit with whether or not you know
I wanted to be in this relationship I
asked her to change a few things and we
went into therapy together and she did
and so we just keep growing we keep
getting better and better better
understanding of each other and you know
and I think now at my age I'm probably
safe to be with her for another 25 years
I know how to avoid the temptations you
know and I play with fire a little bit
sometimes and that I'm in those
positions and having fun but it's just
like I just don't think after 27 years
of not cheating I'm gonna go out and she
yeah
[Applause]
how'd your poker skills help you away
from the table
you mentioned negotiation are there any
other areas in which you can think poker
has helped you I don't know I have to
think about that I mean maybe the answer
is everything I mean it could be
everything yeah I mean it just I want a
lot of my friends who would love poker
we're not professional players by any
stretch of the imagination but I had one
friend of mine very well-educated guy I
mean he has a tattoo of a semicolon I
was poor it's like what very
well-educated guy John who says that he
learned all he needs to know about sort
of navigating the world from his
learning of book I have one so my friend
Allen Mishra who cured tennis elbow
I didn't oh you know Allen Allen
yeah Allen is one of the foremost
experts in something called
platelet-rich plasma PRP injections so
they take out your whole blood they spin
it in a centrifuge and they isolate the
growth factors and then re-inject it
locally into injuries like tennis always
been in the New York Times fascinating
guy yeah amazing guy he came to me in o2
and said I have this PRP thing yeah so I
got involved with him but really I'm
like dude you're gonna change the world
he's like that's just what I needed to
hear and so I've invited my poker camps
and we hang out and right now we're in a
suicide Football League together we have
one team left it's just one where you
have to pick a winner each week yeah but
you can only pick a team once per year
and so by the end you're picking
Cleveland and some other teams haven't
won many games got it okay but anyway
Allen told me that you know playing
poker has helped him read his patients
these high-profile patients come to him
and he says well did you hurt your knee
doing this and if they hesitate he's
like no true answers coming like he he
can have you been taking your medicine
the last three weeks and he can tell
whether they're lying or telling the
truth and that's good for him because
then he can do
a better program for that huh fantastic
doctor hard to get ahold of amazing very
very popular confident guy well he's the
guy that invented the you know the
surgery that Kobe had in the knee where
he went to Germany Allen invented PRP
Allen owns the US patents on PRP and yet
when Kobe goes over to Germany no one
mentions Allen Mishra's name is the
inventor it's some doctor in Germany
yeah it's amazing what he can do imagine
this folks you have your own blood he
spins out the PRP okay the growth
hormone let's just say that you have
Alzheimers they pour the PRP and the
area with alzheimerís he thinks that
maybe one area that he can help say you
had a heart attack they've already
proven that your heart will come back
85% better with your own blood so
imagine we've been searching the top of
the Himalayas for amazing things when
it's inside your blood all this ability
to cure and and Allen's working on some
curing cancer stuff which is amazing and
I I don't know I I don't know I maybe
I'm naive I believe he has a decent shot
to I believe he's gonna cure cancer he's
let me just this this small world story
I mean it's worth pointing out I mean
I'm not originally from the Bay Area
you're not originated from the Bay Area
I got advice very early on this is on my
answering machine actually way back in
the day from a mentor and he said you're
the average of the five people you
associate with most I was like huh and
that's been one of the pieces of advice
is guided a lot of my decisions one of
which was where to move to live
so the Burien you just happened to bump
into people like tellin mushroom it's
amazing uh when you hear the word yeah
he's a crazy guy he just said hey he
just went to the Nobel Prize winners and
said hey I have a new concept you know
how we're trying to starve cancer cells
I'm just gonna feed them platelet-rich
plasma and see how that works yeah you
know so they there's been some progress
yeah so I'll probably sounds stupid you
can keep this in but I'll probably sound
stupid saying he's gonna I think he's
gonna cure cancer but I'm sticking by ya
he's certainly cure a lot of other stuff
so yeah he's a brilliant guy no one
knows his name yeah that's true when you
hear the word successful who is the
first person who comes to mind for you
and why Wow
I mean I think of I think of some of my
best friends I think of Shemah Valley
Hypatia mm-hmm
I think of Billy people don't really
unless you're a business insider you
haven't heard of these guys yeah can you
explain why is that you're thinking if
you think what Alon must done is beyond
success what he's doing you know he
thinks we live in a matrix you know he
he's sending people to Mars
he has Tesla he has SpaceX he's that's
extraordinary and sorry I was thinking
shimoff Polly Appetit and Milly yes so
why are these two very famous investors
at this point again nobody in the room
knows their name so why are they what
makes them successful to you well the
thing I like about I think I define
success a little bit differently socha
moth I mean I tease him that he got
lucky he didn't want to go to Facebook
they just kept giving him more and more
stock he's like I don't know if this
thing's gonna work so finally he took
the stock and went so you know each
point is worth what 2 billion now yeah
he's done pretty well so but it's what
he's done he plays poker great he his
family's great he is an amazing wife
Bridget and three young children and I
see the effort that he puts into like
you know they used to as a lot of people
in Silicon Valley the three nannies the
maids all that kind of stuff and these
guys have gone a little bit away from
that and Hamas he's been cooking meals
for his wife and kids a little bit which
I've never done but it's amazing to me
he's put family first yeah and yet still
changed the world mm-hmm
you know deployed billions 1.2 billion
dollars now out into the field he's
crushing it right and then I look at my
friend Billy who
you know spends a fair amount of time in
his backyard with his young kids and and
you know deals come to him as you know
he's really good friends with a lot musk
I think when Elan flies over to Paris to
do a climate change there's one other
guy in the plane it's bill and bill
because bill is brilliant and you want
bill with you because bill is gonna help
you write your climate speech you know
when the gigafactory opens you want
Billy
next to you you know and so these guys
they're living there having really nice
lives and Bill is one of the best angel
investors in history yeah maybe the best
angel investor in history we don't know
but he's been an involved with but he
sits in his backyard and I'll go by what
was two days ago I went we had lunch
together and we had a drink and just
kind of chilled you know and that's and
I'll go to his house once a week and
spend four hours in the afternoon
sitting in the back yard he is you know
a one-year-old and a three-year-old na
six-year-old and they're coming by
always spicing up the atmosphere and it
just I enjoy that I enjoy the the
friendship thing I didn't get that I
didn't get that until 2010 I was all
about poker and family and then I just I
kind of realized it's seeped into my
life the importance of strong
friendships definitely so there's a
concept of forgiveness that's hugely
important and so for me personally when
I was studying Buddhism we spent a week
at Esalen Kathy and I my wife and I a
week at Esalen we weren't allowed to
talk Iceland for those guys who don't
know sister I deal with spot in Big Sur
it's an essence us like spiritual place
that was famous from the 60s
as natural Hot Springs and it's really
fun and so when I studied Buddhism the
concept of forgiveness was important I
had someone steal $28,000 from me now
understand I was staking this guy I was
feeding his family of that $28,000 that
he had online that he stole for me
14,000 was his only to do is call me and
say Phil I need 7,000 you take 7,000
will leave 14,000 on instead he chose to
steal 28,000 from me when I got the
phone call that this has happened I said
what happened and I was in shock
this guy just stole 28,000 from me I'm
sending money to his family I'm staking
him what's going on here and and I
called my friend John Bonetti Ben he's
like Fri am released the evidence crush
him destroy him for life we had the
evidence neat pile of evidence released
on the internet he's destroyed for life
but what good does that do me know what
good and so I was just furious and
steaming and whatever and I called the
guy and he was crying on the phone and I
finally just decided honey you and I are
going out to dinner we're gonna have the
most expensive dinner in the most
expensive bottle of wine I can have
because my life is amazing and I've
spent one hour or two hours of my time
steaming because someone stole from me
we went out we had a really nice dinner
at the end of that dinner I said I'm
gonna completely forgive the guy nothing
was ever released
but here's some beauty here's what I
didn't expect I got paid back in full
this guy defends me to everybody on the
planet
my wife said he's turned into a like a
protector of yours so now this is a big
profile guy he's defending me to
everybody telling everybody what a great
guy I am
and I remember the other amazing thing
about this this happened on a Monday
night
I could have released it all hell breaks
loose the internet just goes crazy in
the poker world instead I flew to
Connecticut to play in a poker
tournament $10,000 buying on Friday you
can't make this up you can't I saw the
guy walked on me at the hallway I shook
his hand it hurt a little bit it hurt a
little bit but I shook his hand I
wouldn't give him a hug I'd shook his
hand but I never had to worry about him
again after shaking his hand right no
this is the freaky thing I played in
that tournament now if I were at war
with him and I don't know he couldn't
say anything negative about me but he
might just start throwing mud trying to
come up with stuff right I don't know he
couldn't he could never attack me right
but people would make [ __ ] up right yeah
so rather than in some mud throwing
contest my mind is focused on the poker
tournament you can't make that guy catch
I want two hundred and eighty thousand
dollars for third place for two hundred
and eighty thousand exactly ten times
what you lost what had been stolen from
me so I got the two hundred eighty
thousand the guy paid me back in full
and he's been a protector of mine all
because I forgave this really bad act
bad actor act right so I love the
concept of forgiveness this is the only
time I have another great forgiveness
story in fact I'm gonna tell it because
if anything makes us edit I want the
forgiveness stuff to make the Edit okay
another guy who I used to play poker
with in the 80s in Madison Wisconsin he
made sure that I was banned from the big
game he didn't want me to play in the
big game in Madison he banned me
so there's a lot of animosity towards my
is he afraid of losing or why didn't
what you play
partly that probably thought I was
acting up a little bit but I think it
was mostly he didn't want me in the game
because I was winning so much money in
Madison he banned me for three years I
moved in 1993 in 1994 I saw him with
some other friends and I invited him out
to a movie we went out to a dinner and a
movie and that was nice as I could be
and I completely forgive him okay in
your head or in my head yeah and
sometimes that's an act where I'll lie
down on a bed I'll close my eyes and
I'll try to meditate and I'll send love
towards that person that I hate I'll
just waves of love whatever that means
to the individual but when I'm doing
that I usually am on the bed a long time
because I'm like well I have to send
love to all the people I love to so I'm
there 20 minutes but I don't know I
can't explain it to you then the very
next time I see someone like that who
have sent love too it's like they've
received it so did they just notice that
my demeanor towards some change that I'm
happy to see them or what happened I
don't know I can't explain it so
whatever this guy so this guy calls me
three years later and led me to and said
hey listen I recommended you for this
deal and I made like 14 million dollars
[Music]
so I got to tell you I'm into
forgiveness yeah so I forgive everybody
so now but I haven't had I haven't had
some other really horrible stuff happen
you know like I don't know rape or stuff
like that I don't I wouldn't know how to
counsel someone who's really traumatic
stuff happen you know but I know for me
forgiving people stealing from me and
all this other stuff has led to amazing
results and I have no hatred in my heart
I get to walk around happy every day you
know and again I think it's really huge
I'll say it again
when you're walking down any hallway and
anybody in the planet walks towards you
I don't have to turn left or right I
think it's also you know I remember
saying to myself at one point that you
know if you're offended easily because I
am offended easily have some anger
issues sometimes you're a bad resource
allocator it's a bad use of this finite
resources your energy and calories and
hours on this planet when you're awake
so for me it's like alright well it's
kind of a two-for-one if you forgive
people you get the altruism but you also
get the practicality and then you get
these unforeseen ripple effects later I
wasn't expecting the ripple effects yeah
but it happened yeah I mean it was just
wonderful I'm like wow this is there's
something I'm gonna do the rest of my
life so yeah I've had guys like I've had
guys write 80 negative blogs about me
they're not the way I play poker mm-hmm
never cross the line to personal yeah
maybe a little bit in there and forgave
those guys I knew this guy who attacked
me all this time that actually kind of
loved me so I forgave him and we moved
on and we're friends so I've never
written a read
I've never written anything negative
about him ever but it's okay yeah I
don't feel the need to you know so I
want to maybe take a hard left turn and
talk about turning away from forgiveness
I'm going to rampage forgiveness to
rampage don't worry we're not gonna end
on a salad II knew what that was about
we're not gonna know sour notes so you
told the story last night right well I
was having some Malbec let's be honest
and you told the UM going on the rampage
story now it was was this in Europe or
was it somewhere else
so that we had a three hundred thousand
dollar buying tournament in May and and
I decided there was a three hundred K
there's another hundred K another
hundred K and so I thought you know what
I've been bad at raising money to play
poker have that one guy staked me I had
made him like 1.5 million it's been
great but let me try this other way and
so I reached out to my friends but I
wasn't sure they would respond so I
reached out so I thought but I only want
to reach out once
so in this email I'm gonna list I'm
gonna say the first thing it's a
high-risk investment you're putting up
five hundred and forty thousand dollars
for me to play six tournaments high-risk
so be aware you're probably gonna lose
your money that's how I led the email
and then and I said I listed the events
when they would be on television because
it's kind of fun when you're staking
someone to watch them live on television
they're playing your money you're live
on television like that's my horse man
yeah I mean that's like better than
having somebody in the Kentucky Derby
the Derby only lasts 60 seconds yeah you
get you they got to watch me play if you
got to be nervous for hours yes watch me
play twenty hours of live television in
this event or more than that and so it's
kind of cool so I sent it out and I also
put wiring instructions
I said let's see what happens five
hundred and forty thousand dollars so
I'll take I'll take a ten percent free
roll and I'll put in the first fifty
four thousand that way I'm playing for
twenty percent all right let's see what
happens well within twenty hours I sold
up and then people were mad at me
because I didn't get him in so so now
I'm playing this $300,000 buying
tournament and it's live on Fox Sports
Net and weird on day two or whatever I
think gets sold out at forty eight
players
we're on day two it's late and maybe
even day three and I'm feeling boxed in
what does that mean I have a young great
player on my right Dan Smith another
great player phaidor Holtz on my left
who's been crushing it in 2016 just
crushing it and there's somebody
else there and I just felt like they're
on to me they're playing me too well and
I said screw this
I might bust myself but I'm gonna try
something else I said this is it they're
just they're too attuned to me
well they've also have years of tape on
you correct so I said I'm on a rampage
raise it and I'm throwing the chips in
and I'm saying I'm on a rampage like
once every 15 seconds I'm on a rampage
I'm gonna I raised ten pots in a row and
they're like from being this compeition
Phil told us and raising and they're
just like I just saw the looks in their
faces what the hell is going on here
raise it raise it raise it well the
whole cards are flashing to the world
nine deuce officer Jack four offsuit you
know seven deuce off suit just nothing
I'm not even looking at my hands I don't
even look at a hand during my rampage
raise it raise it raise it I'm on a
rampage I'm on a rampage I'm winning
every pot accumulating all these chips
and I'm like all right I messed up their
flow yeah right and I'm and if they do
call I'm betting the flop abetting the
turn firing just throwing chips in there
and I'm saying I'm on a rampage I'm on a
rampage it was great television
two things happened one I'm finally in
the big blind all the backers like I got
those emails the next day
trust me so now I'm in the big blind I
hadn't look at my whole cards there's a
guy in the small blind and I said I'm on
a rampage everybody else had fold they
don't dare raise my blind he's like
all-in he puts two million in I looked
down at Queens I call 700,000 he has a
nine and a ten I win that point I'm at
one point four million and I'm on a
rampage and I'm on a rampage I'm going
on and on about it and finally finally I
slowed down now the next day so I did
this no one understands on the planet
why I did this this is one reason why
I'm a bad poker player they say right
what I'm trying to do is just lose my
mind be crazy and let him know you're
not bluffing me for this next twenty
hands you are not gonna Bluff me you
might beat me but if you rear ace me I'm
calling all your re-raises - I'm telling
them you raised me I'm calling so let's
just get it on you know I don't it just
doesn't matter
to me it's all threatened bluster and I
probably would have called them if they
rear ace me because that's just what I
was gonna do you know and so but it
really changed the dynamics of the game
now of course the next day I had like
five different investors emailing me
Phil don't lose it like that again Phil
what were you thinking Phil what are you
doing why are you playing nine too soft
so why are you playing jak3 offsuit you
know all of these commentary you know
and I'm just like I'm like doesn't
anybody see the brilliance of what I did
no they see the insanity of what I just
did there
one in the same right it's like everyone
has a plan until they get punched in the
face custom auto trader might expect
you have a pretty theory now let me go
on a rampage so we're gonna wrap up with
some of it by the way some of the some
of the highest ratings ever in poker
history yeah I mean no I'm sure I mean
to watch me go crazy like that those
clips have been watched just a ton
ladies and gentlemen Phil Hellmuth
[Applause]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
podcast is brought to you by mizzen and
Maine many of you longtime listeners
know how I feel about visit and name
they make the most comfortable dress
shirts in the world quite possibly they
use advanced performance fabrics which
provides stretch and comfort but that's
not the real selling point to me that's
all great it's all really good but they
are the only dress shirts so to speak
that I travel with because you don't
have to iron them no more steaming no
more headache I can just punch them up
and throw them in a bag pull them out
and no one will be the wiser they're
fancy enough for important dinners but
made from athletic sweat wicking
material so they're all-purpose and
hundreds of pro athletes love these
shirts including NFL all-pro JJ Watt and
last time these guys were on the show
they sold out of every item they feature
every single SKU so if you're interested
in getting a shirt you might want to
check them out on the faster side just
go to Tim blog or slash shirts and you
can receive $50 off when you purchase
three or more shirts so check it out
Tim dot blog vote slash shirts
this episode is brought to you by
movement watches that is spelled MV MT
movement watches I first became aware of
this company back in 2014 when there a
brand brand new baby company because
they won first place in Shopify's built
a business competition the founders are
two college dropouts who wanted to wear
fancy watches but had one wee little
problem they couldn't afford fancy
watches so they decided to scratch their
own itch since then their high quality
affordable watches have gone from
startup to more than 1 million watches
sold across 160 countries it's an
awesome success story and when you check
out the product you'll know why they
offer classic design quality
construction and many different modern
styles so you can really pick one that
suits you you might want to start one I
would suggest probably appeal to a lot
of folks out there's the classic black
silver so search classic white silver
the guys at movement have a great offer
for listeners of this podcast they're
offering 15% off your entire purchase
with free shipping and free returns if
you're dissatisfied for any reason and
they are very very famous for their
customer support
just visit movement watches comm forward
slash Tim that's MV MT watches comm
forward slash Tim
[Applause]